salud en directo américa de france 24 ya
está conmigo en el estudio más romeros a
la mar bienvenida feliz mañana del lunes
lo hablamos el viernes que supuestamente
y seguramente dijimos que el sábado iba
a pasar esta noticia y cual noticia
estamos hablando de que ya la vida del
mono es una emergencia de salud pública
según la organización mundial de la
salud está más pero del viernes no nos
tocó pero pues le hablamos por supuesto
del lunes si al final lo hoy nos da la
oportunidad de hablarlo con un poquito
más de calma y también con las voces de
la asesoría de nuestros asesores
científicos precisamente como decía raúl
una decisión que ya se esperaba y es
importante recordar que este tipo de
decisiones de declarar una emergencia
pública no se toman según el número de
casos que haya por ejemplo si no pues
por qué tipo de respuesta necesita esto
es lo que vamos a discutir ahora y lo
recordamos pues porque no tiene por qué
implicar que ya estamos frente a una
nueva pandemia como y hay mucha gente
que tenemos mucha gente tiene este medio
pero porque estamos todos un poquito
traumado yo creo después de estos dos
años para analizar toda esta información
estamos con carlos pérez médico
infectólogo de la universidad nacional
que nos acompaña un lunes más doctor muy
buenos días empecemos por el principio
qué implicaciones tiene que se haya
declarado esta emergencia de salud
pública internacional
mar buenos días lo que de lo que se
trata es el aunar esfuerzos y que se
unifiquen los esfuerzos para identificar
diagnosticar con tener tratar y prevenir
una enfermedad cuando se ha declarado la
emergencia es que se alerta a todos los
países para ser sincrónicos a la presión
de estos pacientes y el direccionamiento
y que los esfuerzos deben de ser
reactivos a ser proactivos pero que sean
coordinados esta declaración de
emergencia es importante porque nos
normaliza en cómo vamos a hacer el
diagnóstico el tratamiento y afrontar
globalmente un problema que se venía
gestando desde hace varios meses y pues
que ya llegó esta declaratoria para
poner en práctica lo que estas
implementaciones globales en cada una de
las regiones del mundo doctor de salud
muy buena mañana del lunes le pregunto
qué ejemplos además de la pandemia de
kobe 19 la más reciente tenemos de
enfermedades que se han declarado ya de
emergencia
rounds son variadas por ejemplo el ébola
siempre estaba en este contexto hay
brotes recientes que han aparecido en
áfrica de ola hay recientemente un caso
de fiebre de mar book crimea vermú que
en españa y hay otros virus que han
aparecido como el vídeos de cica y todos
estos virus están bajo humana integridad
epidemiológica para poder detectar si
hay un aumento en la incidencia de los
casos si estás saliéndose de
proporciones para poder hacer una dieta
es respuesta global es fundamental la
monitoría la vigilancia y sobre todo la
coordinación global porque estas
enfermedades generalmente me tienen
países de baja tecnología y cuando
reaccionamos pues se hace una forma que
ya se poder controlar la fuente y puede
ser tardía doctor la organización
mundial de la salud ha tenido algunas
veces unas críticas por haber declarado
la emergencia muy tarde como pasó por
ejemplo con el commit 19 pero otras
veces en otros casos también se le ha
criticado por declarar la muy pronto
quería preguntarle su opinión en este
caso la opinión que le merece que hoy
bueno que este sábado se haya declarado
esta emergencia por la viruela del mono
en una precisión personal yo también
creo que es algo más reactivo es un poco
tardío realmente los casos sean
documentales de hace varios meses y ya
había una documentación de casos
regionales así fueran en regiones de
europa y en ciertas poblaciones digamos
simplemente se volvió algo de noticia
para no hacer un esfuerzo global ya está
en más de 75 países son más de 16.000
casos y definitivamente necesitamos
pedagogía sobre todo recursos para
métodos diagnósticos de tratamiento y
que las vacunas existentes y nuevas
vacunas empiecen a ser efectivamente
colocadas para poder hacer los cercos y
no permitir esa expansión lo que hacía
un poco tardía pero bueno estamos ante
la alerta y tenemos que trabajar en
conjunto pues para que esta enfermedad
se contenga lo más pronto posible doctor
con todo esto entonces me pregunto si
vamos tarde digamos en respuesta global
para contener este brote de la vida del
mono
no hay otra opción o sea la respuesta
tiene que ser
regional local y global pero no tenemos
otra opción tenemos que coordinar los
esfuerzos porque lo que sucede es que la
migración de las poblaciones hace que
sea muy difícil poder controlarlo en un
solo sitio y entre más allá población
migrante y con los viajes transoceánicos
la migración de las por de las
poblaciones propias además de son las
migraciones internas hace que estos
recursos sobre todo para el diagnóstico
porque generalmente el diagnóstico de
estas enfermedades están concentradas en
las grandes ciudades en las grandes
universidades y los enfermos están des
en las pequeñas ciudades o por fuera en
los ámbitos rurales donde no están las
herramientas de diagnóstico se necesita
ese esfuerzo global para poder que esta
enfermedad que puede tomar otro curso de
aumentar los casos la respuesta de las
ciencias sea también a nivel regional
local pero mandada por un mandato global
unificado doctor precisamente estaba
mencionando esa tecnología la necesidad
que hace a veces en los países donde se
diagnostican estos brotes quería
recordar que habíamos explicado a veces
en algunas crónicas anteriores que aquí
en los epidemiólogos africanos llevaban
a meses incluso años advirtiendo de que
estaban creciendo los casos de viruela
del mono y que tenía el potencial de
convertirse en de nuevo una emergencia
global que afectará otros países esto
finalmente ha pasado yo quería
preguntarle que tenemos que hacer para
prepararnos mejor porque es que salimos
del cómic 19 y volvemos a entrar a otra
emergencia aunque no tenga las mismas
dimensiones y estamos repitiendo algunos
errores del pasado incluso con la
vacunación no que podemos hacer para
evitar que esto siga sucediendo
lo primero es la pedagogía
lo segundo es la monitor ya que sea
global y lo tercero ya aprendimos que
estas alertas sanitarias no son
solamente titulares de prensa sino son
realmente una importancia global y
debemos enfocar nuestros esfuerzos
para poderla contener básicamente más
del 90% de estas infecciones que son
emergentes han aparecido en el
continente africano debemos prestar
mucha más atención en tecnología en
recursos en atención para poder mitigar
el origen de las de donde están
sucediendo estas enfermedades pero
también hemos visto que somos muy
reactivos esperamos a que hayan varios
casos para poder fortalecer los
laboratorios creo que se necesita que
ese liderazgo que ha tenido la
organización mundial de más patente y
aunar esfuerzos para que se controle
esta enfermedad es en su sitio de origen
si logramos contra el sitio origen te
dejarán de ser emergencias globales y no
esperan a que sean emergencias globales
para atenderlas en las regiones locales
entonces ahora sí es importante áfrica
mientras nos venía advirtiendo desde
hace más de 10 años
que esto podía suceder por supuesto
siempre tenemos que escuchar y a veces
dejar un poco de lado esas dinámicas tan
del norte global que nos hacen no tener
en cuenta esto pero quería hacerle
todavía otra pregunta y es cuál es dado
en la situación en la que estamos actual
dadas las cifras que tenemos ahora cuál
es el mejor escenario en el que nos
podemos encontrar dado pues respecto al
brote de vida del mono y el peor
escenario cuál es el riesgo más alto al
que nos estamos enfrentando en este
momento
básicamente es una enfermedad de muy
baja natalidad solamente se han descrito
5 casos de fallecidos todos en el
continente africano y esta variedad de
virus de la costa occidental es el que
tiene menor virulencia es decir que lo
que esperaríamos sería en el peor
escenario un gran aumento de casos pero
no un impacto en la mortalidad otra cosa
importante y en el mejor de los casos es
que podamos identificar aislar y vacunar
en una estrategia anillo a estos
círculos cercanos para evitar que haya
nuevos casos y desarrollar vacunas para
que en el continente africano se esté
haciendo masivamente esa vacunación y en
las regiones donde se ha documentado
para que no haya un desarrollo de la
enfermedad y se pueda contener la
medicina veterinaria es muy importante
que haga parte porque este es un virus
que circularán los animales la medicina
humana la salud pública los gobiernos y
sobre todo una estrategia global para
contener en el punto del ying la
enfermedad las vacunas se necesitan
desarrollar pero se necesitan aplicar y
donde en áfrica donde están los casos y
obviamente donde están emergiendo los
casos nuevos pero tenemos que hacer un
esfuerzo y constante para esto doctor
carlos como siempre muchísimas gracias
por acompañarnos todos los lunes en este
espacio